what is going on with Apple's iPhone 14
Pros just when Apple is starting to pay
out from their first battery gate issue
people are complaining about these new
expensive smartphones having really poor
battery capacity and not only that but
really bad real world battery life as
well in this video I'm going to share
with you guys some info that we have
about what is going on why we could be
having these issues and what Apple could
do to fix this just a few months ago I
made a video giving you guys some very
helpful tips on how to maximize your
battery life on your iPhone so that it
would last a long time that video has a
lot of info but at that time I had 99
battery capacity while Angelica our main
editor had a hundred percent but fast
forward to three months well now I am at
91. she is at 92 and Aaron from
zollotech is at 90
whereas his 13 Pro Max that one after a
year of daily use was at 98 what's even
crazier is that Sam and John from The
Genius Bar podcast recently talked about
their battery capacities and John is now
at 88 battery capacity less than a year
since this phone launched and is 13 Pro
last year was at 96 after a year and the
interesting thing is he's been charging
both identically using the Maxi Duo
which actually only puts out 12 watts of
Max save charging instead of 15 so
that's less heat and less power than
normally now see him on the other hand
what he is saying is that his battery
capacity is really bad as well and now
he is only getting four hours of screen
on time before he has to charge his
phone so daily he has to charge his
phone before the end of the day feet and
that sucks for him and with that he
doesn't even use the always-on display
now when these phones came out I was
testing out both the 14 pro and the 14
pro Max and after about a month I
decided that I absolutely had to go for
the 14 pro Max even though I didn't want
to I like the smaller size it's more
comfortable in the hand with the regular
14 pro just because of battery life
because that phone would not get me
through the day which was not an issue
with the 13 pros and Sam saying the same
thing where next year this kind of stuff
keeps happening he will have to go to a
large phone which he hasn't done in the
past just because of battery life now
looking through nine to five Max article
on this they actually made a list of
other creatives and people on social
media about what they're getting and
that this is not an isolated incident
and even looking through the comments
there are a lot of people that are
complaining about these issues so
there's definitely something wrong now
most Android manufacturers don't give a
battery health and that might make sense
with a lot of them having crazy fast
charging for the phones much faster than
Apple's and the only reason that we
actually even have this on an iPhone is
because of Apple's original battery gate
for a long time people speculated that
Apple would slow down older iPhones and
the reasoning was to get you to upgrade
to a newer phone and then it came out
where a Reddit user did some testing and
found that his phone slowed down
significantly with newer iOS software
and this is going to apply to the 14s
here in just a little bit once this came
out Apple had to admit that it was
slowing down certain phones they had to
give a public apology about this and
their reasoning was the batteries were
degrading and instead of having issues
with your phone they actually slowed the
phone down and that was supposed to help
it but they didn't let anybody know they
just hid this and then once it came out
they had to settle for 500 million
dollars to pay people back with that Tim
Cook had to put out a statement saying
that they are going to give us an option
to turn that throttling down in software
it could give you maybe some other
issues but that was going to go out and
along with that and along with that they
dropped the price of replacing your
battery to 29 instead of 80. and now
years later they are just now in October
a couple months from now going to start
paying people back for that and people
get a whopping 65 bucks if you were
affected which is kind of laughable
because with phone slowing down that
actually made people want to go out and
buy a newer phone because their old one
was slow and that might have been a
reason why why people used to upgrade
their phone every one to two years
instead of now where they're lasting a
lot longer and now in the UK there is a
new lawsuit about this that is equaling
two billion dollars much more than that
500 million because Apple was being a
bit Shady so now that we've had the
option to see our battery capacity we
can see what is actually going on with
our phones and these 14 Pros well the
battery is draining and the capacity is
getting lowered much quicker than before
and with these new phones the question
starts to come up why are we seeing such
a big drain like people have noticed in
our comments that you're going from high
percentages and then slowly before the
launch of a new iPhone the percentage of
your capacity is dropping like mad is
this an issue with these new iPhones or
is this software that is now showing you
that Your Capacity is much lower really
quick where for half a year or more
you're sitting at about a hundred
percent now just like we know about the
battery life on these iPhones where it
says at 100 for a long time and then out
one percent for a very long time on
iPhones that's manipulated to give you a
more confident feel that when you charge
your phone you're good to go you're
using it you can go out uh and then it
starts dropping much faster so are we
getting the same thing with these phones
where for the first half a year I feel
happy and then when you're getting close
to the new launch of the iPhone Your
Capacity drops and then you start to
consider should I upgrade because we're
having issues with this or is it just an
issue like I thought and talked about in
my review where we have new technology
in these new iPhones that are causing
the battery to heat up much more so
we're not going to know until Apple
addresses it and hopefully they will but
what can we do as far as a solution well
one of the things I talked about in my
video about increasing your battery
capacity is to use a 5 watt slow charger
at least at night the only downside to
that is sometimes you do need a top up
quickly so do you need to own two
Chargers and what about if you love
magsafe like we do and you just have
that convenience factor of being able to
attach your phone instantly pick it up
it's a really nice easy solution so Luke
miani talked about this on Twitter about
these issues and this is something that
we actually covered before in our
comparisons to some Android phones where
Apple could give us the ability in
software to turn off fast charging or to
schedule it OnePlus has done a great job
with this even with their wireless
chargers where at night if you're
charging you don't need to have a charge
up quickly so it'll go into lower
wattage mode for a longer period of time
and then if you start charging your
phone during the day well in that case
your phone will charge really quickly in
order to get you Juiced up because you
need it and and if you guys take a look
at the one UI they have a lot of
different options here so you can toggle
those and then another thing I talked
about in my video and how to extend your
battery life is charging your phone to
80 percent or 85 or 90 just like you
would on a Tesla if you need a full
charge you can do it if you're going on
a trip on your Tesla but day to day you
can charge it up to 80 and 90 that's
what they recommend and that makes your
battery last way way longer because that
last little bit actually hurts your
battery especially if your battery stays
there so this is something that I love
Apple to implement because we could use
one charger be it magsafe or be it a
wall charger and then if you don't need
fast charging that is going to help your
battery to maintain its capacity and
this would be a very easy fix in
software to be able to implement this
and then give us the option also to cap
at 80 or 90 percent which the battery
life especially on these big ones are
good enough to do that and now also be a
big help and Android companies are doing
this and they've been giving people
those options so you guys let me know
what you think about it let me know your
capacity if you have an iPhone 14 pro or
a pro Max and if you would like some of
these software options and if you think
this is a big enough deal for Apple to
put out a statement about I want to hear
your guys's thoughts go ahead and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there there's been nox and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign